hey hey how's it going nice to be here
yeah Russian band The Ramones you like
him
oh yeah but he's from Flushing
originally opposed before my time to be
honest before I mean I'm no not before
my I guess I was a kid when they were
really popular but I never really
listened to him I discovered them to
hook up with some girl who was like into
them and then I me and her didn't worked
out but I wanted loving the Ramones
yes she got me into the Ramones right
positive benefits of a bad relationship
I just wear the t-shirts cuz I think
it's cool
they are cool they make you look really
really edgy and that's what I thought
people like oh you like punk I'm like
yeah that's just me a younger former New
York any bands you were a fan of as a
kid that you loved that just didn't age
well and you just can't listen to it
anymore
poison yeah I didn't really love poison
though Village People but I can still
enjoy enjoy the Village People there are
some 80s metal bands that I loved and I
just I can't figure out why now as an
adult and I found an appreciation for
the bands that came before my bands like
Hendrix and the stones and the doors who
were way before my time and the 80s
middle bands and I like I went through
what a lot of people my age went through
and which was a limp Biskit phase yeah
at no point in my life today would I
listen to a limp Biskit song but at the
time as I guess this is [ __ ] dope
wasn't I forget that you were born here
are you so nice you think of me as an
Irish guy a the Irish guy yeah fusing I
know you don't live there Nadia none I'm
living in New York living in the Lower
East Side okay what why'd you move back
ah something new something fresh oh you
got sick of it no it's just you know my
parents you know my mother was getting
it you know it's just like it was like a
life decision it wasn't like it wasn't
any specific thing and yeah I mean it's
fun to be back here doing it doing it in
America so it's really just like a life
challenge when were you popular there oh
yeah Ireland yeah
because I did cover up the name yeah I
died I could I would I wouldn't know I
felt bad I I did Dublin it was fun
I like I really enjoyed being that was
recently right yeah but it was nice the
people where the weather sucked but it
was like it was nice to go that's the
Irish experience the weather sucked but
we had a great time doors open they're
everywhere every story going to the
[ __ ] doors are open I'm like what's
wrong with these people why wouldn't you
meet me freezing no the doors were open
yeah it was crazy you sit there having
coffee in a shop I was friend of mine
lives there and I'm like why do you
people leave your doors
and she's like what are you talking
about and now she texted me she's like I
thought he says yeah whatever she was
anybody in Europe I've never noticed
that she did and now she can't unsee it
she's like every place has the doors
open I never noticed it it's very energy
inefficient yes I will say that when I
moved to iron lives 1990 14 years old
and I loved it because it was new and
exciting then I came back to New York
for Christmas 1991 and when I went back
one of the things I really remember was
I'm so homesick because it was cold and
wet I hadn't noticed it the first time
but after coming back to like proper
heating in New York when I went back I
was like oh my god I'm cold and wet all
the time so I guess I was experiencing
that maybe you were experiencing yeah I
liked it but I definitely could not live
there maybe I should go over the summer
no it's literally the worst possible
whether you like you breathe in and you
have bronchitis for three weeks that's
it oh it sucks oh it's terrible it's
very damp
it's very moist - a big local comedy
scene there it's small but it's its
success they they punch above their
weight the Irish so the comedy scene is
small but it's only an hour flight to
London so it's really kind yeah it's
really kind of part of its in addition
to the UK comedy scene a lot of people
make the mistake of going there and
saying it's great to be in the UK and
then you've lost the crowd for for your
entire show even if they've waited like
like Chris Rock made the mistake once of
talking about Ricky Hatton the boxer and
then sort of saying you guys along with
Ricky hat so he wasn't even saying the
UK he just made the mistake of including
Ricky Hatton in the the sort of Irish
Shore and they kind of turned on him for
the rest of the show and they it was in
a tiny venue they waited like eight
months to see him and then they were
just like now I'm sorry you should have
known that Ricky Hatton and us have
nothing in common which Irish pride
before everything right absolutely
well you know it's just that you can't
say the UK they go nuts or even if you
say the British Isles because you know
and we were educated like growing up
here you're taught that Ireland is part
of the British Isles quote/unquote the
Irish don't like that huh who's the
[ __ ] that I watched those
bare-knuckle fighters I mean my dad
talked about this last time who are
those guys like their truck the
travellers yes now they're gypsies they
are Irish gypsies yeah so where are they
frowned on in Ireland well the Irish the
travellers are like the they're very
discriminating Colin Quinn's obsessed
with them with the travelers yeah like
he'll tweet videos he'll say something
about you know let you know something I
do I did this yesterday and this is some
shitty travellers video
two guys under cloudy skies [ __ ]
bare-knuckle fighting apart yeah I mean
I actually did I did a like a
documentary series about doing stand-up
comedy workshops in bad areas so I did
one I lived with them for a month the
traveller entomb tu AM but they say to
him like a CH home I thought let anybody
on the outside hit well I mean you know
they do if they can no I mean in these
guys are settled travelers so they live
in houses but they all live amongst them
you know each other and I mean they were
great I mean they're great fun but they
have you know there's like all
marginalized disadvantaged groups they
have some social problems did they drink
they drink a lot they get violent when
they drink they're they're sort of
feudal so they have a lot of feuds you
know that like they're kind of tribal I
should say so they have a lot of feuds
right and when families turn against
each other it can be quite bloody and
violent but not so much with guns but
with like axes and machetes and stuff
like that oh wow there was a group of
travelers that got exposed here in the
United States that's right in the sense
massive [ __ ] scam where there was
this whole backstory how the women we're
looking for men online who had just
become widows and they move in with
these old guys and say my my brother is
down on his luck can we get him to move
in and it would be their boyfriend and
they'd be [ __ ] their boyfriend in the
same house with an old guy living
upstairs and just waiting for the old
guy to die while they take over but they
didn't kill him they didn't kill him
they would just wait for the guy to die
they would work their way into his life
and then get in the will and then get to
get the house pretty smart and that bit
of patience recorded that that deserves
respect you are a [ __ ] someone in
their eighties and you see that the
[ __ ] the husband too but the whole
ring got exposed in this massive huge
scam they were about to pull off on
Disney they went to the Disneyland Hotel
in Anaheim and staged a rape in the
Disneyland Hotel they busted the door of
this hotel room and they actually beat
up one of the girls like their own and
came on her and and they you know had to
fight off the volunteers for that game
Wow part of it sure and she calls the
front desk weren't they might worried
that like they'd find like the guy's DNA
in the jizz and then that guy is
front desk and says I you know my front
door was kicked in I've just been
gang-raped and and then they investigate
and and they go man you know and then
they've start this lawsuit against
Disney and it goes on for a couple years
and they're about to settle for a huge
amount of money with Disney and there
was some infighting amongst the women in
the travelers group about how to split
the money and one of them said if you
don't give me this much I'm exposing the
whole thing and she did they were just
about to settle for tens of millions of
dollars with Disney and she [ __ ] do
you think they hate her I always wonder
what happened to that girl and that but
yeah I remember I wouldn't want to think
about it too much because statistics
would show it didn't end well for her
really yeah there's a lot of problems
within that community and I I stick up
for them all the time but there is a lot
of instances of domestic Sofia well
because the Irish are really tough on
them but I didn't grow up with it how
did you how did you stay with them they
treated you well they treated me great
they took me lamp and rabbits so you go
out and you go out with flashlights the
midland night and the flashlights scare
the rabbits the rabbits start running
and the the whippets the great you know
you know what a whip it is now kind of
mini greyhound the whip it goes and
kills the rabbit and they eat it but we
yeah we ate it with them you see oh
absolutely the irish give them a hard
time why oh they're they're hated I mean
because well you know the people would
say that they're just genetically
predisposed to violence and anyway think
of any group that's hated for irrational
reasons think of your favorite and then
you'll find the evidence to say these
people are like that if you want to find
that evidence and it's just classic
racism I saw one of them one of those
guys in an interview okay I went on a
loop Colin tweeted some [ __ ] dumb
video and I was in a traveller's loop
and one of the guys soaks his hands and
gasps I'll never forget that just
toughen your hands and I believed him he
was a big [ __ ] material travelers he
might have been he might have been the
King a guy who fights a lot there's a
weird he hits a real thing by the way I
fought one of them in a boxing match as
part of you had gloves yeah I had when
you fight I mean I was all right I held
my own the kid was the kid was smaller
than me
we tried to take a lawsuit in work but
uh yeah he would sound like 17 but I was
a lot taller than him but we had a good
fight Joe Joyce it might have been I
don't know who is Joe joy the joy the
Joyce is a big traveller named McDonough
is a big traveler named in the wards the
people that I were with were the wards
some of you a choice I haven't met Joe
Joyce in fact I didn't meet any choices
so these are these travelers like I
spent a little bit of time growing up in
England like I spent four years there
and there was a good gypsy culture where
people would just show up in RVs and
just Park them yeah that's the Irish
travelers and that's where they would
just live I mean there are also Romani
gypsies but there are many gypsies are
they just look kind of European that
just look different yeah those are
traditionally what we think of as
gypsies but the Irish travels are the
once you're there words like this pack
of like RVs that were literally pop out
of the road yeah they weren't they were
outside of our school and they just
every single day they were just there
and everybody just knew don't don't [ __ ]
with the gypsies they bother you or no
punks no as long as you didn't go into
their space and we never did what are
you going to this you couldn't walk by
them no we were on the just dangerous oh
yeah then why they're criminals no
they're just they're rough just crappy
no me ask you this defending their
territory right like well I you know I
mean listen it's a they're very paranoid
they are how are they fun crowd you
perform for them
oh I performed for the men four of their
own perform for them one of their
favorite jokes is if if you say oh can I
can i buy this off yeah and you say yeah
and they say when you take a traveler's
check this is my life and also my cousin
by the way there's a lot of inbreeding
yeah yeah but that's like a real thing I
think was like a Dateline special or a
couple of Dateline specials and one of
them show they would do these pageants
where they would show off their youngest
females and their families to be traded
for marriage and the girls were like 10
11 yeah I mean yeah there's all sorts of
stuff and you know there's a series on
channel 4 in the UK called My Big Fat
Gypsy Wedding which is actually all
about Irish Traveller weddings they have
that they have Big Fat Gypsy Wedding
here oh they do
but it's not like gypsy is like in the
European sense it's more just like this
like I think like a little Romanian
cultural like it's it's
gypsies which are not a thing oh okay
yeah yeah I know and in the UK it's
mostly the Irish travels My Big Fat
Gypsy Wedding in there you know they're
like holy community like the First Holy
Communion for the travel is like
unbelievable horse-drawn carriages
really they're all dialed up they spend
and it's funny because they're all on
social welfare but then people say
they're on social welfare but they spent
so much money on their communion dresses
there's all sorts so they yeah they're
poor well they're poor quote-unquote
they're poor yeah and you watch them
fight bare-knuckled they were mouth
guards they fight bare uncle I don't
think so I've never seen a live
bare-knuckle fight I've seen them the
same as you have on YouTube okay step
into this middle lettuce foot and they
had their own voice like you can tell
the traveller from their accent really
yeah absolutely but we matter what part
of Ireland they're from they have a
traveler accent so it does it's almost
like when people do this Tara typical
gay voice doesn't matter if you're
northern or southern it's hi like it
doesn't yeah transcend I mean actually
one of them coincidentally enough one of
the travelers that did our series was
gay but he wasn't camp how did his
people handle it well I don't know
because he came out afterwards but there
was a lot of rumors that he was gay but
he came out after my fight I bet he
could really fight no I don't think he
could fight but he had other skills
manipulation skills beyond beyond is
beyond his knuckles when you see just
beyond when you say there are
quote-unquote poor is that because on
the books they're poor but they know
they're yeah there's a lot of stuff with
guys on social welfare got caught like
having loads of money and you know a lot
of them into antiques I mean they have
they have certain things that they're
good at you know they're good at selling
antiques and how they get come about
getting them is the the problem but
anyway listen I how do I know and I
would have done a little bit more
research on the chilli they're [ __ ]
fighting everyone else has their [ __ ]
hands in their pockets and wearing
jackets Salamun that's belly man that's
on the outskirts of Dublin where they're
fighting so actually I've met a few of
these travelers they're probably Joyce's
in fact years ago I was doing I was
doing I was running workshops in Irish
prisons for addicts and are you said
doing your sober right yeah I used to do
a thing every Wednesday and one of these
travelers would used to come in every
Wednesday his last name was Joyce I
can't remember his first name but he was
in he got caught robbing nappies which
sorry diapers he got caught in the in
the diaper warehouse robbing diapers and
so he was doing like five years for
robbing diapers yeah the Irish people
called them nappies you know what a
valeurs in ireland are they similar to
the Irish travelers in the Appalachians
where they have like crime like sin to
cancer there they're all relieved that's
the same breathe they run they run scams
and the guys do the guys were doing like
repair work they would travel them for a
couple days a hundred miles or 200 miles
in any random direction and just show up
into neighborhoods and go hey we can't
we notice you got a thing in your house
and then they would pretend to work on
the house while they stole everything
out of the house and then drive a couple
hundred miles back home yeah yeah that's
then there's Irish travelers in the
south I know that I know that they've
gotten caught for first things and I
think one of there was one horrible kid
thing that went down with the Irish
travelers years ago I can't remember but
the news in Ireland was that Irish
travels are getting up to no good in the
south of America I don't think they
thrive here in New York all these
communities got to have their scams to
make money I went and visited the Amish
at one point in like you know whatever
central Pennsylvania or whatever and
they give you the the horse and buggy
tours but the thing must have stopped
like five or six times with different
Amish kids being like oh and we're gonna
stop right here and you can buy some
lemonade and cookies we're gonna stop
right here you can buy this right here
you could buy this wait a minute Amish
I'm punching each other in the face
Mennonite recently Mennonite girl was
sitting next to me on the flight to
Calgary well and what those are I know
my friend Raymond the Amish comic he's
actually a funny Amish comedian and he
would talk about the Mennonites what's
the difference between them and the
Amish they hate each other
no they don't hate each other dude
there's all different sexes of this
Germanic tribe that came over 400 years
ago some of them are more you know more
modern than others I mean her one was uh
they used the Internet only for commerce
she never watches TV which is funny
because it was a TV screen right in
front of her on the plane and she
wouldn't use it yeah she wouldn't use it
but you know that's the Calgary she
flies to Calgary to see her boyfriend
who's teaching in a Mennonite school in
Calgary so she use an airplane but not a
television yeah but you know it's all
just whatever but she was very upset
when I told her I didn't believe in
Jesus give me a hard time but she was
very upset she couldn't believe it and
then she couldn´t believe I wasn't
married are you have you ever been
married
no I was engaged what
and long story okay she W oh well she
dumped me but I guess she had no choice
oh no the bad guy in the picture you are
a cheat I don't yeah I've never talked
about it publicly so I'm not gonna start
because you know like in Ireland I would
you know just be better if I didn't talk
about public I love many stories like
about cheating yeah keep my [ __ ] mouth
shut that's probably the smarter way to
do it that is probably the better way to
do it yeah okay so you are engaged and
now are you dating now or no D just date
her currently no oh you know III was I
think the last time I was on with he was
a previous incarnation of your show I
think we did talk about that I was with
a Chinese girl but I I was with the
Chinese girl quite seriously but it
didn't work out she didn't want to
emigrate to here at Ireland to here to
here okay yeah I guess they're either
sure she's from China today I'm it's all
the same yes it's not China yeah did you
meet someone in tribe way over there I
was there for two years
did you really [ __ ] it or maybe you
might have told me this and my memory is
so bad that was a that was a weird time
anyway but no I I did a TV series where
I lived in China for a year to learn
Chinese to do stand-up in Chinese did
you do it no I did it yeah and when I
stayed another year because I liked it
so much how was it it was great too in
gig but that's it that's like a an
amazing like you really have to be
committed to a TV show to be like okay
here's the pitch I'm gonna live in China
for a year yeah smart guy maybe l22
yelled specifically Chinese news I wash
wash no no not that I've heard that
before
where in China did you live in Beijing
amazing yeah we know I yeah anyway just
in terms of the pitch I had all the TV
shows I've done in Ireland have been
these kind of like immersion experiences
like including like the traveler thing
and I did the Irish language and I lived
in an Irish speaking area so the China
thing was just an evolution of what the
called isn't Gaelic Who am I wrong yeah
the Irish language in in Irish is
actually gaeilge but somehow they're
like a bastardization of has become
Gaelic but you know let me say it people
say Gaelic here so that's fine so when
you do gigs over there is it China no no
in Ireland there's not you know there's
obviously the IRA with the north the
south and there's all this I I know
there's a little about it yeah but is it
are you more well received in one area
than another or I'm Way more famous in
the Republic of Ireland the South
quote/unquote even though part of this
of southern are there's actually more
north than Northern Ireland but I'm
quite famous in the 26 counties and then
I'm semi-famous in the north because
they watch a lot more British TV because
they get all those channels like you
know they're just more accustomed to
watching English TV but amongst the kind
of nationalist community particularly
when I did the Irish language thing
because they really hold on to the Irish
language as part of their Irish or
entity like the Montreal in the French
yeah so they they love me because I you
know well actually two reasons one I
speak Irish and two Irish American and
we funded them through the 80s and 90s
until they stopped fighting okay so so
I'm a big fan or they're big fans of
mine in fact Gerry Adams and Mary
McAleese the leader oh sorry ignore that
that would their name I just said the
actual name has popped out of my head
for a second but anyway the leader of
shin Fane they're both over here at the
moment to raise money for the party
Gerry Adams is not in charge anymore
no he just passed it over did you know
him I've interviewed him in in Irish
actually really yes the English for that
series yeah no no he speaks English his
English is way better than his Irish but
okay I interviewed him for in the name
of the Father was the name of that
series father is like the Irish accent
so I was like a play on words means
nothing over here obviously people
always say that to me like why don't you
just move to America and doing your
jokes anyway III interviewed him for
that but then of course some people
loved it and then some people like how
can you talk to that murdering bastard
you know so there's a lot of lot of
mixed feelings about Gerry Adams there
are when you do what made you start
doing so much of the immersion stuff
like the are you just interested in the
other experiences or you just like this
is something like the first time by
accident so the first one was a series
about living a minimum wage mm-hmm so I
did four minimum-wage jobs for a month
each and it came to me via this is this
is not some undercover boss [ __ ]
like they where it's just like today I'm
gonna be yeah yeah sure can you do it
for three hours
there was a book called nickel-and-dime
the great book by Barbara Ehrenreich
which was a hot book at the time so she
was undercover because she's a printer
but we had permission from all the jobs
but anyway she pitched this idea to me
and said I'd like you to be the guy so
then when I did that that was the thing
that kind of broke me big in Ireland so
this concept of sort of like immersing
yourself in an experience I guess one it
kind of suited me because I spent my
whole life living in other people's
lives so I'm good at being like a
chameleon just fitting in and - it's
good because it's a foot it's a you can
be entertaining but also informative
about difficult situation right but the
thing about that series that was 2003 we
filmed in 2004 was on TV
Ireland literally got immigration for
the first time ever you know everybody
always left Ireland now suddenly Ireland
had an economy so people were coming
there so I ended up working with a lot
of Chinese and a lot of like like
Romanians and Eastern Europeans so it
was Ireland's first look at sort of how
Irish people treat foreign workers
because I would be Irish people were
traditionally the people's like Oh in
America they love us in the UK they
hated us in the 80s because of the IRA
you know it was always like the
immigrant experience so this was the
first immigrant experience so that was
part of why it was so successful by the
way des is a really really funny
comedian probably never we're talking
about this doctor by the way you're
gonna be a Caroline Thursday through
Saturday I've we worked together a
hundred times the Comedy Cellar scene
you really are great comic and it's at
des bishop des bishop on twitter and des
but you've got dotnet on Instagram and
Desmond has decided but Caroline's two
one two seven five seven forty one
hundred this Thursday through Saturday
before just to plug that because people
thank you especially because we're
getting so deep into stuff remind them
I'm a comedian though it's interesting
cuz I get so many experiences I have not
had I've just started doing a lot of the
travelling and to immerse yourself I
guess I get so attached to things and
like I'm doing in gigs to immerse myself
anywhere for four months would I would
freak me out yeah yeah do you take a
break from stand-up when you're doing
stuff like that
well no with the China one no I mean
with the China when I was doing stand-up
all time I actually started my own kind
of like gig the english-language gig
originally and then when the Chinese
thing started kicking off we ran like a
Chinese language stand-up thing and to
be honest I was so obsessed / addicted
to at that I stayed an extra year
because it was so much fun to be at
literally the dawn of stand-up in China
was there anything about Chinese culture
that threw you through me yeah I saw
some weird I really
I wanted to go to the opening or the
first few months when the Shanghai
Disney oh yeah was open I wanted to see
it because I thought it'd be cool to go
to a new park and and I was I was
obsessing over videos I was just about
to buy my plane ticket when I saw this
guy who calls himself Disney Dan posted
a bunch of videos of his experience at
the opening of Disney and there was one
video labeled just to heads-up about
Disney in Shanghai and he said hey just
so you know there's some things that
might throw you first of all people here
don't respect personal space and he
showed multiple pictures in line were
people people's shoes were touching his
shoes they were dick to ass on him in
line physically touching him and the one
like he said that really [ __ ] me up
was and just so you're not shocked when
you see this there are multiple signs
all over Shanghai Disney saying if you
have to go to the bathroom please use
the restroom
yeah because just kids that's the kids
because kids in China apparently they
all wear onesies yeah they look like
flap the bunny lap they just drop a
deuce they just drop a deuce and there's
apparently a video of the opening of
Disney Shanghai of a kid taking a [ __ ]
in the middle of Main Street USA at what
age do kids in China stop [ __ ] all
over the street yeah when they learn how
to use the toilet
yeah they just have a hole in their in
their stuff and can little Chinese kids
walk around that you can see their ass
and parents will hold the kids over
garbage while they [ __ ] in public yeah
and you gotta say they're not shy huh
pretty good system oh and Starbucks I
was in Starbucks one time in Tiananmen
like right right behind Tiananmen
there's like a little like like tourist
street and this little kid just [ __ ]
pissed like right next to us and the P
just like rolled down by our feet ah
Starbucks in the outside part of
Starbucks that's not a good system yeah
well you would the hole in the floor
that you got a [ __ ] into might might
find wallets you love it you learn to
love that why because you don't have to
[ __ ] sit on the toilet no but you're
they're so disgusting
that you're just no matter how this now
dirty they are you're just you're just
crouching there that's not actually that
you kidding me that's a premier toilet
in China but don't you drop you a
[ __ ] wallet and stuff and keys in the
mall you don't don't that's that's what
freaked me out these guys like read the
paper
smoked [ __ ] hang out in there they
must have really shot why is yeah this
good honestly the squatting was the best
thing ever like it opened up my hips I I
actually miss squatting toilets you know
that sometimes they say they stand on
our toilets there's been loads of signs
now like they've had to put signs up in
big tourist spots where Chinese go to
say don't stand on the toilet oh they
stay standing [ __ ] into it because they
don't want to sit on the toilet cuz they
think it's disgusting and they're kind
of I guess in a way they're right but
there are a lot of dirty like that yeah
I've had some footage in that one on the
right there that that was we did a scene
in one of those that was quite yeah
there's some disgusting but and they
have some that there's no barricade in
between em is just [ __ ] yeah that's
the majority of oh my god
they don't care you realize who gives a
[ __ ] but what if you Lynch's balance
yeah exactly just don't I did see one
where there was maggots the does she
there was maggots in the toilet
did you squish could you go to another
one I went to another I couldn't handle
it did you smell it look like that is
that a real bathroom which one yeah
there's plenty of bathrooms like that
yeah that's Haram they're stepping in
today walk around in sandals they're
stepping in [ __ ] dope a mine that's just
but it's getting better you know it's
men oh good this is the privilege this
is the Western privilege that you don't
understand you've been living wit some
walking and [ __ ] just clean that up that
stop you know what they could just clean
it oh you should mention that because
when we were in the northeast of China
we did I did a month where I actually
worked in a restaurant that was like
part of the series and we did a scene in
the disgusting toilet we filmed it and
like three days later it was completely
clean because we had permission to film
in the town so they obviously got wind
of the fact that we had taken footage
from the shitty toilet so that it was
cleaned up yes they can clean stuff you
know they absolutely can clean it if
they think it's gonna be on western
television they clean everything up but
they do oh yeah they don't like that
actually we didn't have our guy
eventually so there's like a government
guy that watches you film all the time
but what happens is eventually he sees
that your your your your motivation is
it's good that you're not there to just
make China look like [ __ ] he leaves you
off so what
and he was with us we could never film
in a toilet it was actually one of the
things that they were really paranoid
about they don't want their shitty
toilets being a Western team some places
hate it when you film in the bathroom
yeah but I will say in China's defense
they have a lot of public toilets so the
fact that there's a lot of shitty
toilets well you need to stop like holes
in the ground yeah but you if you're
[ __ ] go for a jog like for example I
get jogging in Beijing if your stomach
turns which can happen just from the
food it's like [ __ ] in New York where do
you go like it's hard to find a place of
a [ __ ] our buddy Jing there's always a
toilet within like 300 yards he's right
our buddy Nikko
there's our intern here he [ __ ] himself
on a bus he did and if there have been
some toilets around yes he did China you
would have been able to jump off and
know that you were within 100 yards of a
public toilet so right now they head to
the Western hotels have like sit toilets
yeah yeah yeah
most places that have any standards have
sit toilets nowadays everyone in New
York has monaster I lived with a family
for a year they had sit toilet everyone
in New York has mastered the art of
walking into a restaurant going hey I'm
gonna sit right here where's your
restroom at take a [ __ ] grab your jack
and go back yeah oh yeah yeah I find
that people have gotten a lot better
with that actually in New York I feel
like New York has become a lot
friendlier most places it's just like
it's cool take a [ __ ] oh you find so
yeah I haven't had to do it much I'm so
[ __ ] crazy about where I [ __ ] like
really I'm out of my mind you what are
you a wipe wet wipe guy when I can I'm
Brahma I'm a literally wipe out my
[ __ ] until there's nothing on the
paper maniac like I [ __ ] I gotta be nude
when I [ __ ] very abrasive if I have to
yeah
well I feel better yeah I mean I
honestly from living in China I've just
been completely liberal I will [ __ ]
anywhere like I say my [ __ ] in the
cellar toilet all the time do you really
yeah I know
that's an a- toilet and beijing dude
I've taken probably three shits there
since 1995 Wow I don't [ __ ] there at all
yeah IIIi have taken three shits there
in the last month have you really i [ __ ]
there all the time must make you feel
like like best friends with the African
guy that looks after the village
underground toilet oh you [ __ ] there too
every single time I do a shot oh yeah I
know that guy who you are next and I tip
are you next
yeah are you
so do you akiza know what to say to a
comedian
no noise when you are on so much noise
he always this is the other comment
that's why I guess he wants more money I
think he does to you he never
compliments me come on next I throw them
five human eyes you give him five yeah
well give them two but I [ __ ] there's so
much
no I only pissed there oh you only
pissed no I mean I should I definitely
give him at least $10 a week because I'm
in there a lot you want to feel like
such a man that you had that ability did
you [ __ ] anywhere I don't feel like such
a man I just have you [ __ ] a lot so
problems are nobody before a gig I will
always have to [ __ ] you know what I got
a [ __ ] empty out too before a big yet
everybody has a nice laxative in the
world really currently set it on stage
like the comedy just makes you have two
shits just nerves sometimes a very
stylist cone do you find a relationship
between how big and nasty of a [ __ ] and
how good the show goes like if it's a
really big [ __ ] that's a better show no
but what I do find is if you get one of
those is this uncomfortable whew Jim I
just know I could drink cocoa talking
about this I find if if I have one of
those nice like just flow and there's no
cut off right just that I feel better
when I walk out but by the time I'm on
stage I've forgotten but when I have a
horrible one that like has left me
feeling a bit yeah you mind fulfilled
yes I'm not sort of like a tender I'm
walking out I think oh [ __ ] I'm gonna be
thinking about this on stage but
actually it disappears yeah the
adrenaline really like I've had to puke
right before I walked in yeah the
adrenaline most not always most times
I've had moments on stage well like I
think I'm gonna vomit but most times the
adrenaline shoots through and it gets
you through that out with you on the
road for one of your gigs this is
helping you out
oh yeah that's that was in the Harford
pencil that's where it was yes yes yes
and I remember because I had to give you
your light make sure your camera was on
and all this stuff get the merge set up
but something that we ate there or
something gave me a diarrhea problem and
I ended up like you know making sure
your camera was set up you go on stage
and I don't want to tell you and so as
soon as you're on stage is doing your
thing I ran to the bathroom and I'm
sitting there and I swear to god I just
got my last wife
why pin and button down my pants and ran
out and time to put the light up the
entire set I was on the you shot the
whole time whole time here's an hour I
thought I felt much better after
cramping wow I mean yeah I am ready for
that one
oh my god I was like oh this it'll be
really bad and I'm like Kim get get on
stage get on stage Jim get on stage and
then ran it is weird I've been
physically ill at a gig or had a bad
cold or a fever and I walk on stage and
I feel completely fine for that hour
that I'm up there and then get offstage
and then and then whatever yeah yeah
it'll get you through anything
it does it does help when you're
especially that when you're feeling
queasy or you're in a [ __ ] puke we
just don't know you know it's the worst
it's the worst I've only once in my my
entire comedy career that I have to just
walk offstage oh so ill I'd come back
from Thailand and whatever I picked up
it was horrific were you sick or did you
eat best something bad no no I was just
really really sick and I tried to do the
show and I just I literally had to walk
off and so what he didn't you tell I'm
sorry I'm saying I'm sorry guys I can't
I can't
I feel like you're gonna shake I felt
terrible but I just find I was late to
get onstage because I was dropping and
then they were like you know Dez but I
heard the Apollo site and then isn't
that do you ever do you fear that when
you're sitting on the toilet before you
go onstage they're gonna call you up
early do you ever have that fear I
haven't do you know why I'm pissing but
I'm also like I've had it happen so many
times it happened in Australia my
manager panicked and it's like she's
like no [ __ ] the other comic they got to
stand there and eat it because I'm not
working out so they have to just realize
they [ __ ] up and you also have it so
you're funny opening when you can walk
out and they know that something [ __ ]
went wrong right they I never mind I try
not to have it happen but my fear would
be dribble you know like like no I I'm
rushing so I put it in too early and
then I got dribble oh my team that's my
first ten minutes look down while you're
on stage just double-check yeah I've
done that before on stage going today no
I'm good no triple yeah yeah you
wouldn't mind a little bit of dribble on
your pants you wouldn't mind letting the
audience know that baby boy had an
accident [ __ ] I'm not circumcised so I
have to always a little bit extra
attention to the dribble oh you're
unclipped
I wish I was too so when you go back sex
will feel better I think you take it
retain sense yeah I have no comparison
but I do believe that that is the case
it's probably the case so now you're in
the States how long you staying here for
good well I'm going to Australia on
Sunday but that's just for six weeks I
mean I'm here six weeks ago you really
[ __ ] travel so you don't get attached
to things faster you do I have the part
of the Buddhist practice of
non-attachment no no I've just been
travelling for quite a while now so I'm
just used to it I mean I guess
eventually I'll settle down but you know
I'm a single guy you know we've entered
into the we've entered into the midlife
your midlife Seattle freedom holiday on
49 I'm 42 but it's like you're single
you're free got to take advantage yeah
go out as much as you can yes you're
singly free you got money now it's like
you enjoy you should be enjoying it
enjoy but I'm going astray for six weeks
but I am based here for the time being
but I haven't completely let go of
Ireland it's just for me right now my
full-time American life is temporary
what happens long term is up in the air
when you are talking to people out to
the shows what type of women do you
avoid now that you used to go yeah let's
let's go so what can you say like what
cuz you're a single guy now you're
traveling you're free so you meet girls
when you're on the road what kind of
women do you avoid now that you would
have hung out with before I don't know
IIIi think I'm still pretty open I mean
like III avoid the same women I used to
you know women I don't find attractive
women that are annoying women that are
too drunk I just avoid them you know but
there's no there's no great difference I
mean I have to be honest man like I'm
pretty well known in Ireland but being
in America gigging American girls are
it's easy to meet women here I've been
shocked actually really yeah there's a
huge difference at how easy it is to
hook up with women yeah really yeah
Amerigo not just like they're definitely
that a little bit more well you look
like des bishop it's quite a lot
different than we do look like Jim
Norton there's probably a different
level of yeah Jim have you found
American girls are very easy to hook up
you know Sam I've not had that
anyway I've just it's been fun GQ or
Slugger the turtle boy you know I
haven't counted I've met a number of
women who have never dealt with with an
uncut penis you know I've had to I've
had to actually instruct them about the
fact that you can't pull back as much as
you're used to because there's a it's
connected all they pulled that oh go
back too far and it's like whoa and
they're like oh [ __ ] what and I'm like
yeah it's just you know it's like you
don't need Lube cuz you got the skin but
you can't pull back too far cause it's
connected there's so much going on I
gotta get rid of the complication he
thinks no ya Jewish propaganda man he
was circumcised as a young adult
oh right yeah but I I had my own issues
but I was 19 when I got circumcised real
issues were complications many times so
yeah sorry no I just tell me quickly so
I know what you do you would know these
guys don't understand but might you know
the opening in the for too tight too
tight Oh yep
it's called phimosis oh it's cool that's
what the doctor said I didn't know about
that part of the story bottomless
phimosis I only had that one I had
thrush what's the rush a yeast infection
male male male yeast infection how'd you
how'd you know you had that to hurt you
just yeah it's just like and it tightens
the skin tight cuz and then your skin
back your foreskin tightens cuz you're
at a yeast infection yeah it's basically
like having chapped lips so you get a
little cracking when you get erect right
yeah I mean men's sexual health with Jim
Sam but wait a minute how do you get a
yeast infection as a guy it's a thing
you can get it yeah you can get if you
run like antibiotic so you can pick it
up off a lady there Candida is the
official term candy what a great song by
Tony Orlando if you want to know ken or
Candida yeah Candida that's it Candida
yeah so anyway III had a run of it for a
while but you know I just have you been
to Australia before can I just talk
about how I ended up not being engaged
I think I take it back I'd rather talk
about that women in Australia we find it
easy to meet women in Australia - yeah
not as much as America I've met a lot on
the movies actually a woman in Austria
right now that I would marry if she
wasn't so far away but won't you bring
her here
she doesn't want to immigrate oh that's
a problem everybody wanted to come to
America yeah you think that you'll find
the percentage just dropped a lot in the
last 13 months we are wearing Australia
she lives in Sydney but she's from
Melbourne so will you spend the whole
time with her there no no i-i'll see
your some of the time okay definitely
are you hitting the comedy clubs are you
doing things I'm doing the fest so I'm
doing Brisbane Comedy Festival then I'm
doing Melbourne Comedy Festival Sydney
coming for someone then I finish up in
Perth and then I come back and then I'm
doing a comedy set of eight oh you know
that the Comedy Cellar has opened and
it's a Wednesday night headline show and
then Thursday Friday Saturday I guess of
just regular like Comedy Cellar like
show yes show our shows yeah it's a
pretty cool I'm gonna guess they're
doing two a night on the weekends I
don't know I said the real I think right
yeah at the Rio yeah I mean I don't know
that much about it other than I'm doing
it the weekend after I get back oh
that's cool yeah that'll be fun yeah I'm
sure I always hoping me and Sam maybe
should go out there one time I like the
broadcast I don't yeah you should
definitely do that yeah been doing right
there I mean hopefully it works out I
hope so into a romantic drive through
the desert yeah sure yeah I want to take
like a [ __ ] uh like like a Pesci and
De Niro one and Casino member they met
in the desert I remember I'd love to
have that disco go over my head a so
great